peter bartlett i'm the associate
director of the simons institute and uh
very happy to introduce bruno alshausen
uh
who's a
professor at the helen wills
neuroscience institute and school of
optometry here at uc berkeley and also
director of the redwood center for
theoretical neuroscience
he's an expert in in visual perception
computational neuroscience and and
particularly computational vision
very exciting to have him talk here
today he was the main organizer for the
brain and computation program that we
held in spring 2018. bruno welcome
thanks uh well first of all
congratulations to shafi and peter and
also before you dick and alistair for
reaching this uh amazing milestone and
also thanks to jim simons for making it
all possible
uh
so as peter mentioned uh christos
christos papani vitru and i
had the great fortune of being able to
organize a program on brain and
computation in spring of 2018
and the goal of this program was to
bring together people from computer
science and also from neuroscience
to rekindle the connections between
these two fields that were actually
present at the very beginnings of both
fields
and uh this is just one of the smoking
gun proofs of that it may be sort of
hard to reconcile this that these two
fields had a very common common origin
computational neuroscience and computer
science and so this paper on the left
side
this paper on the left uh is uh the 1943
paper by bukola can pits which is for
many of us in computational neuroscience
sort of the root node
uh of our field uh it laid the
foundations for many of the models and
that we use today in computational
um neuroscience
and uh and but um unbeknownst to many
people uh this this this paper was
actually also very inspirational to john
von neumann uh so john von neumann was
was very much uh in contact and close
contact with mcculloch and pitts as they
were devising these models
uh in in in it was a very influential on
him to him in designing the the first
computer
and so what's shown here on the left
below is these diagrams from mcculloch
and pitz's paper
walter pitts was very enamored
about
for enamored of logic he'd read russell
and whitehead's uh book and so he was he
was asking the question well how do how
do we do logic what's the neural
underpinnings of this in our brain so we
reasoned and hypothesized there must be
neural circuits that compute logical
functions in our brain and this is his
his basically hypothesized some of his
hypothesized circuits
and it's hard for us to believe when we
look at this today but these drawings
here in his paper were really the first
drawings of logic gates
and if you go and read uh john von
neumann's repeat report here on the
edvac computer um
then you see that there's basically two
uh two citations in his report both are
mcculloch and pits
and so these these logic diagrams that
you see in his paper um this is where
he's saying it right here uh where
basically follow mcculloch pits um in in
in in this design strategy of how to
sort of how to sort of conceptualize
these these logic gates
so it's curious that these two appeals
uh were you know they they began
very much very much connected
but they sort of uh at least most of
most of our lifetimes uh have grown more
disparate over time
uh but but very recently there has been
a rejuvenation uh of this connection
and and these connections are growing
very rapidly and so i'd like to share
with you some of these some of these
exciting developments today
uh and so so many of these revolve
around
this idea of neuromorphic computing
neuromorphic computing was initially the
term was initially coined and this this
area basically was invented by carver
mead
in the late 1980s and early 1990s
and uh so carver media is recognized by
many people as one of the pioneers of
silicon valley he pioneered the process
for for designing a very large-scale
integrated circus vlsi process that that
people used in designing computer chips
and uh in in the 1980s he worked
together with max dilbrook a
biophysicist to try to understand the
biophysical properties by which uh
neurons signal and what occurred to him
is that the the the uh that a lot of the
the physics of transistors which they
use in mosfet transistors which gave
rise to these exponential current
voltage relationships
um were also at play in in in the brain
in in cells and basically those exact
same physical laws that governed these
exponential relationships and nerve
membranes and this would get this is
what gives rise to the nernst potential
which relates the uh the gradient ion
concentrations to membrane voltage
and many of these
and these other uh exponential current
relationship current voltage
relationships you see in neurons and
that's being shown here on the left
and so this inspired him to say well
look if we can see these parallels then
basically maybe we can build systems we
can build physical systems based around
the organizing principles of biology
okay so we can try to capture and
hypothesize what these organizing
principles are and build systems that
that that capture those principles and
this is a way of testing our
understanding right and we'll learn by
building things and we'll learn things
about neuroscience and we'll also have
this sort of way of innovating and
creating new kinds of circuits that can
compute in new ways
so that was the idea and the original
inspiration of neuromorphic computing
and i think there's
uh um you know some parallels to this
and i think maybe what i think i want to
sort of distinguish
between is you know this idea of
capturing the principles versus
biological mimicry just sort of
mimicking what biology does versus
trying to understand the underlying
principles and so there's analogy here
too
to to flight so around the turn of the
century
uh people um people understood the
principles of lift and how to design a
wing and and how that was you know
captured in birds audio although auto
lithium thal was one of the people who
was really avidly studying that the
aerodynamic properties of birds and
trying to build systems they captured
that
that property he built a glider so lots
of people had built gliders they could
glide you know for some distance and it
was successful at that
but the problem that people faced in
1900 then was not only how to glide how
to get something in the air but how to
keep it in the air and how to keep it
stable during a turn so what the problem
they had is that every time they tried
to turn the plane would simply just fall
out of the sky they couldn't keep it
stable
and so the wright brothers were not only
inspired by biology but they adopted the
principles by which biology was working
one thing they noticed is that when
birds turn they twist their wings and
this turned out to be a very important
innovation when it would enable them to
solve the problem of how to keep an
airplane in the air and how to turn it
stably as they attached some cables to
the wings of their airplane so they
could twist and warp the wings so that
when they turned uh that it wouldn't
simply fall out of the sky and basically
the ailerons on a modern airplane are
what serve that function today okay so
the idea is that by confronting the same
problems that biology and evolution had
to solve they were basically able to
learn something test their understanding
and build something new which they
weren't able to do before okay so this
is really i think the approach we want
to try to adopt in um in both
neuroscience and computing right today
it's really a joint and joint endeavor
it's a way of understanding the brain
the things that are mechanisms in the
brain and it's a way of inventing new
kinds of computing machinery
[Music]
so what are these problems how do we how
do we sort of go beyond just biological
mimicry
and try to understand the actual
principles at work and you know what are
the problems that biology is actually
trying to solve
and so here for this i'll turn here to
one of the stages of psychology
perceptual psychology can nakayama so
interestingly the answer to this
question will not come from neuroscience
okay
uh it's going to come from people
studying behavior animal behavior and
neuro neuro ethology
and so this is you know one thing that
ken told me a long time ago is that in
order to understand intelligence we need
to understand his origins okay so what
what was this nervous system created for
what problem was evolution trying to
solve
well it wasn't trying to solve chess and
go right these are things we can do with
our brains we sort of think of these as
things that smart people do who are
intelligent right but that's not the
problem evolution was trying to solve
okay so we can build systems that play
chess and go and we're probably not
going to learn much about how brains
work or have to be confronted with the
same problems that biology and evolution
was trying to
um overcome okay so what are those
problems huh so
so if we think about how systems evolved
well we have to go back to things like
you know spiders and and flies and ants
and things like that and one of the
things that all these systems have to do
is they have to move about in a complex
enriched
three-dimensional environment
and they need to make purposeful actions
to and be able to guide their actions in
this environment to know where they are
how to get from point a to b
and you know where to how to get back to
where they were before where the food
was and so forth and so this is this is
just sort of highlighting two particular
examples from the animal kingdom
um so one is the jumping spider on the
left which has a very complex visual
system has very high resolution vision
it doesn't build a web to extend its
sensory space it uses it relies upon the
vision to do that has eight eyes uh to
survey the world and one of the things
that you know people have been studying
these jumping spiders for a long time
and one things they noticed about them
is when they have to navigate towards a
prey item that's too far for for them to
jump to so normally they capture their
prey by jumping at it but if it's too
far away to jump they have to find a
route to to crawl there to walk there
right
and so this is just showing sort of one
example of people think of a behavior
they've observed in the wild is that
when the jumping spider first
sees a prey item here i'm just trying to
get my highlighter point okay so when
they when the spider first sees
something here that says okay great i'd
like to get that but it's too far for me
to jump so i have to crawl down here and
as a as it's along the way uh to that
route to to getting that it does this
reorienting turn is a very prototypical
kind of behavior it sort of turns as
though to check okay is it still there
is that where it still is and what
they've noticed is that the angle that
it turns at is exactly the right angle
given its new position in the world okay
and so they they set about and studied
this and documented this phenomenon a
number of controlled experiments and
showed that it's actually doing has to
be doing some kind of path integration
to be able to do this to this correctly
it's not simply sort of keeping track of
it in the visual visual field it has
some kind of a model in its head of
where it is in the environment and where
that thing is i want to get to in the
environment and also in other
experiments people show that it can it
can ascertain from vision the
three-dimensional layout of an
environment that helps it uh sort of
plan paths
and the other one example on the right
is the desert ant just showing this sort
of an amazing behavior they exhibit
where you know the ant starts at the
nest and lower right hand corner takes
this kind of meandering path and
eventually finds food in the upper left
and once it finds the food um then it
makes a beeline straight back to the
nest it doesn't just sort of meander
around it knows where it is and this is
the vector i need to go in to get back
to the nest okay so it's kind of
astounding and so both of these examples
were you know head scratchers for people
in neurithology for a long time you know
you know can it be that these animals
are doing trigonometry or something in
their head i mean how are they doing
this
and uh and so you know recently um
astoundingly um
modern neuroscience has sort of given us
the ability to look inside the brains of
animals and see some of this machinery
at work and so this this story began we
actually in in rats where in with the
discovery of head direction cells
and these are cells that that fire in a
way that seems to indicate uh the the
current direction of heading it's not
it's not with respect to some kind of
magnetic orientation it's just you the
the right the animal lays down a
reference frame and then sticks with
that with this neural population so each
neuron fires according to a different
direction that the animal is heading
so the model that people have developed
for the for for capturing this
phenomenon is something called a
continuous attractor neural network it's
very similar to the neural networks that
these these attractor neural network
models they were invented by hopfield in
the early 1980s
except here the ideas instead of storing
a particular pattern what this what this
what this population of neurons does is
it maintains a bump of activity on the
population of neurons
and that represents the heading of the
animal and then when other signals come
in for example from the vestibular
system or the motor system or any number
of different modalities indicating that
the animal is turned right then what the
system does it has to shift that bump
and and hold it at a new location so
that the in the models these neurons are
interconnected by a recurrent neural
network which maintains as a memory that
bump of activity that's the animal's
internal representation of where it's
headed in the world
um and then and then when these when
these external cues come in indicating
that it's turning that does a short-term
modification in the synapses of this
recurrent neural network to allow the
bump to shift and then it holds at its
new location and then it can shift back
if other cues tell us turning it back in
the other direction okay so these models
have been out there for a long time
there's a lot of theory that's been
developed about them it's kind of a
non-trivial theory that you know to get
these these networks to work to make
them stable
uh there's a very interesting set of
models and sort of and almost a kind of
you know uh
an experiment you can only wish for
uh these the uh these these these ring
attractor neurons were discovered in the
fly brain okay so this is a this is a a
nucleus of neurons it's called the
central complex within the fly brain and
one particular nucleus unbelievably
within that um within that structure is
shaped like a doughnut it's shaped like
a torus
and people knew about the anatomically
about the existence of this taurus for a
long time anatomically and only recently
within the work of celiac and tyramine
at hhmi in
howard hughes medical institute uh they
were able to record from the neurons in
this ring during uh while the fly uh not
flies but here just sort of crawls on a
track ball so they can control you know
so they can record from neurons in its
brain and image that and you know again
this is just kind of jaw dropping these
are kind of experiments and technology
that um you know people like myself we
could only dream of that we could do
this kind of thing and now you know in
the year 20 20 22 um you know this is
kind of fairly routine
uh and so here it is you know these this
population of neurons in the fly brain
there's 42 neurons in this ring
attractor neural network and the amazing
thing about flies is that you can do all
kinds of connectomics on them you have
access to the whole population of
neurons that you can record from it so
it's now can be very well characterized
and they can test these these continuous
attractor neural networks models
quantitatively
and so there's this very intimate nice
very intimate connection between sort of
a deep theoretical model very
mathematical kind of computational heavy
model on one hand and these actual
neural structures that you have that you
that we see in the brain that's just
just really unbelievable so this is
these are really exciting developments
and and um
and and and if for those of you want to
know more so one of the people here a
new hire here at berkeley yvette fisher
uh in mcb she's going to be giving a
talk in the redwood center next week
next wednesday actually on the
plasticity in the system so she's
actually going to be starting to record
from these neurons with electrodes so
you could actually measure action
potentials and characterize the activity
on a much finer time scale
okay so so these are these are really
exciting developments that are sort of
bringing around a connection between
theory and experimental neuroscience so
i think the theory is going to start
driving the experiments the experiments
are going to give new insight to the
theorists um in ways that just hasn't
happened uh before and ilafite is going
to talk about some examples of the same
idea um for representing position so in
representing position it turns out the
topology is a taurus unbelievably and
people have been able to recover this
sort of toroidal structure of the
manifold of population of activity in
the rat brain okay so it's very likely
this continuous attractor neural
networks are are you know uh maybe a
thing that you're going to sort of find
in other parts of the brain representing
other modalities maybe color maybe other
kind of continuous quantities that we
have to reason about um in the world and
it's also kind of really uh you know i
think astounding to to contemplate the
fact that you know if this is true and
it appears to be true that this this
sort of holding up so far that this
appears to be a kind of continuous
attractor on the neural network that
evolution invented this model uh this
idea 500 million years ago right so we
we've known about it since 1980 and john
hopfield and other models uh but but you
know evolution knew about this and got
it working uh 500 million years ago so
this is i mean it's just it's really
kind of um astounding whoops um to to
contemplate okay
um so uh so that's so that's i think one
one exciting development and
things things happening and another i
think question that's going to drive a
lot of the work ahead
[Music]
is uh
is is this question of how to compute at
very low energy
levels and at small form factor and this
is this is really something uh that sort
of goes beyond just an implementation
issue it really affects how you think
about what is being computed how you're
going to compute it and the very theory
of computation itself
and so and some some really nice work
along these lines that has come out as
this is a this is a book
by by uh sterling and laughlin that
captures a lot of these principles that
that brains use to compute at very small
form factors with low very low amounts
of energy i mean how do you take
something like an attractor neural
network and put it inside the head of a
fruit fly
right that's like a speck of dust right
so and keep that thing so it's stable
and it operates robustly
and so there's a lot of secrets that
biology uses and these you know these
secrets a lot of them have been they're
not
some of them are still secrets but a lot
of them have just discovered and they're
out there in the literature and this
book does a wonderful job bringing those
things together in one place so i highly
recommend it to everybody as a place to
go for and not just inspiration but to
understand here's a new kind of
electronics here's a new kind of
computing medium um that that
potentially we should try to build
um
and so these are some of the principles
they talk about one is so one in
particular is this idea of making the
components irreducibly small that's so
that we can sort of get signals to to
propagate around just locally we don't
have to send them large distances it
makes things faster and it requires less
power if we can do that if we can keep
everything together in one space and one
example one very nice example of that is
in the retina where we have all this
circuitry which is trying to capture the
information that's captured from cones
and send it to the brain through the
optic nerve that's that you know that
nerve bundle coming out the back and if
you sort of zoom in on the synapse
between the cones and the and the
bipolar cells which is the first you
know synapse relaying this information
within the retina you see this
magnificent world of machinery all
happening with there within the cone
terminal and so i'll just maybe try to
point to some of the structures here so
here is this one of the processes of a
horizontal cell which is conveying the
responses of neighboring cones in
inhibitory fashion so it's attract away
the contributions of neighboring cones
to reduce redundancy and there's also
gap junctions between cones to amplify
signals in in lower light levels
these these little dots here are
synaptic vesicles which are fusing with
the membrane there's all these different
synapses down here with bipolar cells
these bipolar cells basically they
position themselves at different
locations on the cone terminal
to according to what signal amplitude
they want and the speed that they want
that signal at so if you're further away
some of these some of these synapses are
formed further away then things diffuse
more slowly to those and that's actually
exploited productively in the way this
thing is organized so a lot of ha a lot
is happening i think the main message i
mean to convey here is a lot of is
happening here in a very small amount of
space
uh and and the cover illustration on
this book um just illustrates the the
dendritic tree of a pertinent cell and
i'm giving the reference here to another
source of inspiration here a recent uh
manuscript by jan rabbi our own john
rabbi here in eecs
of brains and computers
where he's talking a lot a lot also a
lot about these design principles from
the perspective of an engineer who has
to build circuits and design circuits
and one of the things he points to is
the fact that in our current circuit
technology uh most the most fan in we
can accomplish when in other words the
number of signals you could have
converging on one device is about four
okay about a fan and about four to one
is basically where these circuits seem
to work the best whereas the brain works
on with fannins up in the thousands and
the and the perkins cell which imaged
here on the cover
has a fan end of 200 000 okay so how is
that possible right that's in existence
proof that it is possible to do this
efficiently biology probably probably
does it for a reason and we need to
understand understand why
uh okay so then uh so so it's at the
same time people in the in the
electrical engineering community have
been trying to
uh basically spurred by the end of
moore's law trying to create new
computing fabrics that can do these
kinds of things that they could compute
at lower lower power and and smaller
scales one of the an example of these
are so-called memristor crossbar arrays
and this that's being shown here and and
these work on something a phase change
memory principle where basically at each
of these junctions you change the
resistance
and that allows you to store a value it
can act as a synapse it also does
computation so you can
apply a voltage over it and the amount
of current there will be the product
between between the voltage and the um
or the or your yeah yeah so so
multiplication of the current with the
resistance
uh
and so but one of the things about
designing the things this way this at
these very small scales and low power
consumption is that they behave
stochastically okay so you can't they
they no longer behave deterministically
they're they're going to sort of make
errors uh and so and so you have to sort
of think about well what kind of
computing uh paradigm what kind of
theory of computing could i have that
could work under such conditions where
i'm at very low power
very small scale so things are still i
have some kind of systematic signaling
going on but it's just not perfect um
how can i still do uh reliable
computation in that in that setting and
so so one very promising paradigm that's
been developing um here over the years
is something uh called hd computing it's
basically the idea of computing a
computational system
or a system for computing with high
dimensional vectors
and and so it's basically some ideas
that were proposed back in the early 90s
by people in the connectionist community
and it's been growing uh you know over
the past maybe 25 years or so and
especially rapidly in the past five
years so many many groups all over the
world working on this
our groups here at berkeley in the
redwood center and also with yon rabai
um developing
and trying to push on these ideas and
some of the main players are here today
so so penti canerva has been a main
proponent of this approach and evgeny
ossipoff who's visiting and conducts an
online seminar which is which is
basically going every two weeks so
there's a community of people sort of
adopting this approach and trying to
trying to develop these ideas and it's
really advanced a lot so the basic ideas
shown here
uh is that we're going to take you know
anything that you want to compute with
it could be symbols the you know letters
words a variable that you want to set to
a certain value a number uh a color it
could be the value of a function
continuous quantities and so forth so
anything that you want to compute with
and you take all these quantities and
represent them with a high dimensional
vector and it's in the same space okay
so you pick some dimensionality
typically on the order of a thousand
maybe even as high as ten thousand but
you pick some dimensionality and you
stay in that space okay so it shares
some ideas sort of vaguely with hashing
in a way where you assign a very high
dimensional code to to a symbol but the
difference here is that we have a whole
computational system for manipulating
these vectors and doing computation with
them
in some cases such as binary in other
cases we use complex vectors
shown on the right that's more useful
for representing continuous quantities
there's an algebra that operates over
these vectors
and so for example for representing sets
we superimpose the vectors you can do
key value binding by multiplying the
vectors element wise
uh and spatial relations and and
sequencing so this algo is a very rich
algebra that allows us to to manipulate
information um in this framework and
some of the papers are down here below
so i'll make my slides available i'm
gonna have to skip skip to the end to
make sure so it says you can do
factorization um whoops um
and uh
and and and other things which i'll have
to sort of gloss over here but i just
want to sort of maybe end with one point
here about computing with dynamics this
is another
a very interesting area that's been
advanced
is is basically taking these hard
combinatorial optimization problems in
computer science like traveling salesmen
the classic things in graph cut and so
forth and trying to solve those with
so-called icing machines so it turns out
you can you can map these problems onto
an icing model and the energy function
is shown below and this is the
minimization you have to solve and if
you can minimize this energy function
then you can basically solve you know
traveling salesman or
you know these other kinds of problems
and some other work here at berkeley by
um by uh
by tianji wang and
chad hurry has shown how you can
minimize these these these icing models
with uh using coupled oscillator models
okay so basically instead of just
representing uh minus one and plus one
represent them with a complex phaser and
allow the phase to spin around and the
network and sends it very efficiently
does a relaxation just to find the
ground state of this of this hamiltonian
i'm sorry this energy function they can
they can solve these icing models so
this is another super um exciting
development i just wanted to point you
to uh things happening i think uh a lot
you know so in the neuromorphic realm of
you know showing new new ways that we
can compute and solve these
combinatorically hard
problems that the brain is probably
having to solve at the same time as we
as we see these uh examples of how to
compute with coupled oscillators
uh then we sort of look at the brain now
with with with a new lens it's sort of
very much like the bright brothers you
know it's like if you sort of figured
out how to do this twisting idea uh with
the wings then you look at the version
you said uh that's that's why they're
twisting their wings right and so one
thing we've known about the brains for a
long time is that they oscillate
uh well maybe this is why they oscillate
right and so so i think this is sort of
gives us a new way to look back at what
these oscillations in the brain may
perhaps in a new way and try to
understand what computations this has
long been a mystery what what how do
they contribute to oscillation how do
they contribute to computation
okay so so basically i think the the
button the the bottom line and what i
want to try to convey here is that
these connections between uh computer
science and neuroscience they're growing
uh especially rich i think in this area
of neuromorphic systems that we're going
to learn about brains by trying to build
these same ideas as a way of testing our
understanding and trying to extract
these principles from biology
and i think in terms of theory of
computing one thing we really we really
need is a theory that can encompass uh
not just complexity but also time and
energy
and uh and so maybe uh maybe this will
be the topic of uh hopefully uh maybe
another uh program over the next 10
years sometime so i look for we may be
submitting a proposal soon on that so um
anyways thanks very much and happy happy
to take questions
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks bruno
questions
[Music]
do neurons do just one thing or do they
do multiple things in different
combinations
um definitely the latter
it's it's a very versatile device and
you know you find neurons that
perform functions
in the retina they're shaped in ways
that this allows them to perform shape
functions in the retina that probably
don't happen in other parts of the brain
so it's a kind of a flexible flexible
building block
one more question
[Music]
thanks a lot for the awesome talk so
like some of these ideas you have some
thoughts that how
i ideas can help this machine learning
and artificial intelligence work that is
going on
that we learned from the brain
yeah
so i guess uh
you know i i'm sort of uh maybe pushing
a different message here than the
standard deep learning
analogy there is a lot of parallels
there as well um certainly uh but i
think here it's really you know i think
the question we're trying to understand
here is
how does the brain solve these difficult
optimization problems okay perception is
loaded with these problems that are
very much like traveling salesmen
they're a form of factorization problems
where we have to factorize apart shape
from illumination or the position of an
object away from its shape or the color
and so forth these are really
non-trivial very difficult problems to
solve that the field has struggled with
for a long time
and so i guess the the hope that i see
what i'm very excited about
um
is that this progress you know that's
being made with neuromorphic systems uh
you know sort of using dynamical systems
as a way to solve these problems using
high dimensional vectors taking things
and representing them at high
dimensional space that allows you to do
the things that maybe you weren't able
to do before that that seemed that
seemed intractable and it now gives us
sort of a guiding light that makes them
uh
seem more doable approachable yeah
all right join me in thanking bruno for
a really fascinating job
[Music]